walter ich war nicht mal bereit
durchgegangen
man geht nur durch und bereich wodurch
geschubst hey leute und herzlich
willkommen zur special folge hier des
megaprojekts wo wir alle zusammen in
ender drachen töten
ich möchte mir so ein kleines präsent
machen ein bisschen was schief gelaufen
ist und es war ein bisschen lachen aber
egal wir hatten alle gesagt dass wir den
ender drachen gestern umso gestern
aufgenommen um 6 uhr plattmachen und
salz community aktion mal jedem 22 06
uhr die mojang server und deswegen habe
ich dann einfach die konfi geschrieben
da wir machen das entweder heute noch um
8 uhr oder dann halt nächste woche hat
mich allerdings auf eingestellt ist das
nächste woche machen bin dann halt
trotzdem soll dann erst um halb neun
heute gestern am pc gewartet habe dann
gesehen die wollen gerade anfangs
nämlich gesagt hey komm mit
und da bin ich auch noch zum ende portal
zum end portal geflogen und dann hatten
wohl alle ihre aufnahmen schon gestartet
und ich will bin wohl in der aufnahme
von allen hingeflogen nachzuhelfen
stellen um das portal rom starten die
aufnahme alle springen sonst portal rein
ich so fahre ich muss doch aufnahme
starten
und irgendwann hat mich wohl mit rein
geschubst oder irgend sowas wäre nicht
an die aufnahme gestartet habe bin ich
dann im end gelandet und bin dann
darunter gefallen war ein bisschen
fällig und danach die ganze aufnahme war
noch fällt also tut mir leid das ist der
ganze da so ein bisschen feierlich war
und ich kann aber wenigsten wenn die
halt direkt anfangen ich hab das sei
total verpennt deswegen trotzdem viel
spaß ist als eine verfolgerin zur
nächsten folge typ
trotz des kinos junge mann nicht er wohl
nicht im boden lassen heute drauf jetzt
wieder rein nächsten wochen vorher
stirbt ohne witz nicht abholen kann
jeder kann ich grafik was kann ich
leider niemand abholen weil hier auch
nicht mehr aus im moment ist ja ich bin
doch selbst im endspiel das segment ihr
müsst ihr müsst sich seine ab und mich
damit zu hause machen dass pause wir
brauchen wieder ein bisschen pause erst
mal hast du irgendwie was für mich
irgendwas mit conny allerdings keinen
bogen
lucie wurde wird abgebucht
heute so wenn am geworden aus versehen
ich finde meine leser noch mein alex
noch meine leser getroffen
hier sind im schnitt immer schlecht im
bett gesetzt holte die bienen käfer 7 in
den abspann reingefallen user darauf was
ihr das beste den er verpasst das beste
aller zuschauer gucken bessere uns weil
wir cool hat hier keinen rappen baum
gepflanzt
oft jedoch keine nachher alles ohne den
er auch wie geil das ist alter junge ist
junges alter wer war so dumm und hat das
portal ab das bett abgebaut und ich
komme nie mehr zurück kann in einer an
wissen mitgebracht hat mitgebracht
ich habe ja gucken sie mal ich habe ein
bonbon
also ich hab mein schild jeden fall so
hier ist der entwurf muss ganz ehrlich
sagen wir müssen dahin laufen wo bist du
doch wo du bist alter ich kommt zu dir
ich finde das auch nicht normal besiegen
ich finde ich fand das total doof ohne
witzig war ein gestänge punkte start
noch nie gemacht habe
ich kann nicht mal jemand teleportieren
baby sagt du bist ja
okay ich gehe und nicht gehen ich habe
bunker geburt ich wohne jetzt hast du
dich ja wie ich bin bei mir am
grundstück komplett an die türken die
endermann ok kommen weg ach du scheiße
kommunalen hin kam lukas machen
alle getötet jetzt müssen wir ganz
schnell noch was klar wo gibt's denn
hier so schön ist für ich wollte die
böse dinge tun regel kommt wenig zahlen
wirklich das ist eine lüge wasserstau ja
die kommentierte anders hin ich hab
gerade ich hab gerade alle programme
gestartet und ich bin tot
ach ja das stimmt sogar warum ist
eigentlich nur 20
ich habe gegessen du hast doch gesagt 20
uhr ankommt sind wir da und nicht ich
habe ja ist doch normal
ich habe die wahlen angeguckt dadurch
johnny english angeguckt das hat mich so
gefesselt
ich will noch ganz kurz der wusste ich
ja dann sterben wir sterben beide
springen die mit sich bringen zusammen
11 lena du bist auch nicht ganz klar
kürzlich hat ist unglaublich
ich liebe dich macht sie kaputt macht
sie kaputt seinem weg von meinem
grundstück ist amtlich ist
das werde was wir gehört ja der arena
lena du hast den weg ist dann noch
irgendjemand ich nehme jetzt auch alle
um
zunächst mal um ihn gespielt mein name
selber liegt ein ding warum nicht ich
lebe ja ich lebe in richtung salier wie
nimmst du noch aus ich hab die ganzen
waren gesichert
alex simon du hast alles von mir muss
alles von holz werde sich dadurch kommen
also ich hab nichts mehr ohne scheiß
wegen dir ich habe einen drauf gehauen
ich verklage ich werde mit fff ein
mensch wert ist bei dir oben
du bist hier einzugehen verschwindet
dank hey lass mich ich liebe dich okay
okay halt doch mal ach man nicht